god this grace can give me the strength
to love Josh when others would say he
doesn't deserve it Anna Duggar is proud
she's working it out with her husband
Josh Anna shared this pic their whole
family at the st. Louis Zoo and after
someone commented quote I love seeing
more pictures with Josh in them I know
your journey has been hard but it looks
to me like you have come through it with
grace Anna replied quote thank you for
your kind words redemption is a
beautiful thing loyalty is one of those
fundamental foundational keys in
marriage and I'm grateful for my wife
Josh was the focus of several scandals
in 2015 including being unfaithful to
Anna and admitting to molesting five
minor girls when he was a teen Anna is
amazing Oh
she displays to each one of us what it
means to have unconditional love I think
and she's walking through this better
than any one of us could have ever
imagined
Josh spent over six months in a
faith-based rehab and in 2017 the pair
revealed they had quietly worked on
rebuilding their relationship and family
in April they revealed Anna is currently
pregnant with their sixth baby due in
November
[Music]